the sub will dive to the wreck site
travel over the bow then out across the
debris field
searching for the mysterious piece of
metal
here comes the water kent tommy ready
yeah i wrote you that one how'd she
secure
that secure here we go
a little bit more on there if parks's
theory is correct
it'll be an incredible discovery
connecting a family
across generations
go ahead and start pumping there goes
the swimmer
this is the lf go ahead get clear to
start pumping it's clear
i have armed thrusters we are beginning
to pump in now
the sub begins its long descent
benjamin guggenheim was born into a
wealthy mining family
in philadelphia in 1865.
he was 47 years old when titanic sank
leaving behind a wife and three young
daughters
surface lf depth three eight zero five
heading
three one zero life support good
wreck on sonar roger that lf understand
three eight zero five meters heading
three one zero degrees
with life support good and wreck on
sonar congratulations
the sub has reached the wreck site
you look down there and see pretty i
could see it yeah
actually the visibility is better
looking down yes there's the marconi
room
one of the windows one of the skylights
let's see here
before searching for the remains of the
guggenheim staterooms
the team films additional footage of
other important features for later
analysis
including the area around the captain's
quarters
okay i can barely see it barely
see it yeah it's devastated i see a
glimpse of the tub
next the team turns their attention to
the search for guggenheim staterooms
the debris field is 15 square miles in
size
finding a single piece of metal is like
trying to find
a needle in a haystack
is this the bigger piece no it's not the
bigger piece
what is this i don't think it's
guggenheim either
[Music]
parks is searching for specific
structural features that coincide with
the stateroom's location aboard the ship
this is key to confirming the identity
of the mystery object in the image
we're getting close to something up
there on the left yep
40 meters
[Music]
eyes out eyes out eyes out okay
this might be the guggenheim piece
you see all that ribbing yeah
this might be the behind piece i'm going
to translate translate left yes please
yeah here we go this is it this is this
guggenheim state room right here
right here found it
that's a state room right there that's
guggenheim
[Music]
good job teamwork
surface lf present depth 3802
life support good at guggenheim roger lf
at guggenheim congratulations
[Music]
you